[Music]
so what did your family thing did they
say there's something wrong with this
young man he wants to just do computers
I was kind of considered a little
strange have you ever thought how your
life could be better off if you had
gotten your Harvard degree I'm a weird
dropout because I take college courses
all the time what about Steve Jobs in
those days what was your relationship
with him we were both there at the very
beginning you're the wealthiest man in
the world for 20 years or more is that
more of a burden than a pleasure to be
the wealthiest man in the world would
you fix your time please well people
wouldn't recognize me at might I was
fixed but okay just leave it this way
all right I don't consider myself a
journalist and nobody else would
consider myself a journalist I began to
take on the life of being an interviewer
even though I have a day job running a
private equity firm
how do you define leadership what is it
that makes somebody tick you built one
of the great technology companies the
world on one of the great companies in
the world and now you're building and
operating one of the great foundations
in the world how do you compare the
challenge of building Microsoft to the
challenge of now running the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation I think they
have more in common than people might
expect and the idea that you find what
an innovation is going to be really
stick to it build a team behind that
have some setbacks and successes that
you know kind of a theory of change now
my Microsoft work was when I was very
young I started when I was 17 and that
was my primary focus until I was 53 when
I made the transition and for the early
part of that I was kind of maniacal I
wasn't married no kids I didn't believe
in weekends until I was about 30 I
didn't believe in in vacations at all so
it was incredibly fulfilling to write
the code and be hands-on you know stay
up all night so for my 20s and 30s I
think the Microsoft thing was perfect I
didn't have the breadth of knowledge
that would let me play my role at the
foundation I think was good preparation
and then after I you know met Melinda
got married sort of have kids I was
looking at the world more broadly
thinking about where the well should go
and I'd say they're equally difficult
you always know you could be doing
better that you should learn more that
you know getting building the team and
thinking about things in it in a better
way so you see the positive results but
you always want to do even better so
let's talk about Microsoft for a moment
so you started that when you were in
high school and you were driven to be
involved with computers were you alone
were that many people knew about
computers in those days it's a fairly
special time because computers when I
was young were super expensive and my
friend Paul Allen and I actually snuck
in two places at the University of
Washington
where they had computers that weren't
being used at night and so we were
fascinated by what the computer could do
but very few people are getting exposure
we had to go out of our way and we were
lucky that we did it all and so then
when the idea of moving the computer
onto a chip that Intel would make and it
would make the computer literally
millions of times cheaper than the ones
we were using so both more powerful and
available to people on a personal level
then the idea of okay it would be very
different the software you needed the
way the industry would work we were
super lucky to be there when that was
happening so what did your family think
did they say there's something wrong
with this young man he wants to just do
computers they knew I was obsessed with
computers that I would skip athletics
that I go in overnight that I you know
leave the house sometimes when they
prefer I wouldn't go work at night on
these things and so it was kind of
considered a little strange and the big
moment was when I said instead of going
to part of my senior year that I wanted
to go work for company writing software
so they were great about allowing that
to be my hobby you went to Harvard and
you're dropped out have you ever thought
how your life could be better off if you
had gotten your Harvard degree well I
I'm a weird dropout because I take
college courses all the time I love
learning company courses and things so I
love being a student and there were
smart people around and you know they
fed you and they gave you these nice
grades that made you feel smart so I I
feel it was unfortunate that I didn't
get to stay there but I don't think I
missed any knowledge because you know
whatever I needed to learn I would I was
still in a learning mode so in the early
days you know you were just a college
dropout you were very young looking did
you get taken seriously by businessmen
who are much older for some people that
youth are and geekiness was like eh
should we trust them you know
that's so weird we've never seen
something like that before so yes we had
to fight for acceptance I couldn't rent
cars so I had to take cabs around
because I was too young and you know
probably some people were a little tough
but then as we got a little bit of
success people were fascinated by this
deep belief we had in in software okay
so when Microsoft is moving forward you
decide to take the company public in
1986 six and at that point you are a
billionaire I was doing close to it
within a year of going public I think
there's some important cover that says
the deal that made Bill Gates 360
million or some weird thing like that
all right how did it change your life or
it didn't change your life at all well
that whole period of time was amazing
because I was hiring people as fast as I
could
I had brought in Steve Ballmer who was
very good at that and and he was helping
out you know we had a sense of urgency
that we wanted to lead the way there was
this graphic Center face thing with
Windows that we wanted to do so I was
super busy and the idea that I could
hire so quickly and invest and build
this worldwide company it was
fascinating to me but I was really busy
so you know if some friend had tried to
call me you know I I would have had too
much time for that I was really into
building this company and I was going
out and telling people about the magic
of software which was good for Microsoft
but also helping them understand the
opportunities and the huge change agent
that software and eventually software
plus the internet would would become so
I was having fun it was amazing but I
always thought hey you know we're one
step away from not you know leading here
we got to got to keep doing better when
you had the famous IBM contract you won
the contract to produce their operating
system why did they let you in effect
own it and they had the license it was
that a mistake on their part yeah this
is before graphics interface when you
still just have text on the screen and
so the software ms-dos was a key thing
so it got to be more of a high-end
machine include
as ms-dos they didn't see how big this
machine would be and they their legal
department didn't want to take
responsibility for the source code they
had a fairly limited license and that we
understood that this was a seminal
machine and other people who do similar
machines so that was fairly advantageous
to us they didn't see the values being
in the software they thought that the
hardware was the key and software was
just a sort of necessary thing so they
had realized the vision we had which was
that software over time would be way
more important than Hardware they would
have negotiated probably a different
deal
you have a fair amount of money for
anybody your age at that time certainly
did you say I'll go splurge and buy a
nice car I'll buy an airplane I'll buy a
boat or you just didn't really care
about that I bought one thing that was a
tiny bit of a splurge what was that my
first car that I owned was a Porsche 911
it was used but it was an incredible car
and that was actually when I was down in
Albuquerque and sometimes when I would
want to think at night I just go out and
drive around it at high speed and
fortunately I I didn't kill myself doing
that and what about Steve Jobs in those
days what was your relationship with him
in the early days and how did it change
well we were both there at the very
beginning the Apple one was a kik
computer that Steve Wozniak designed and
he worked with Steve and they came and
offered it at various of these computer
club meetings and we went to lots of
computer club meetings so we were sort
of colleagues in pitching the gospel of
personal computing we were kind of
competitors the the time we work
together most intensely was after the
IBM PC came out Steve had a group
actually a small group at Apple that was
doing the Macintosh and he came to us
early on and asked us if we'd commit
resource so we actually put more people
on the project than Apple did and did
the early application software that used
that Mouse graphics interface and so it
was a huge win Bowl
for Microsoft and for Apple when the
Macintosh became so successful when your
mother first said I'd like you to come
and have dinner with me and Warren
Buffett will be here you should meet him
you didn't seem that interested why was
that well Warren I thought it was
somebody who bought and sold securities
which is a very zero-sum thing that's
not curing disease or a cool piece of
software and the idea of you know kind
of looking at volume curves and that's
why it was so shocking when I met him
[Music]
so your company grows it becomes
successful becomes the most valuable
company in the world at one point at
what point do you say I've made a fair
amount of money I don't need to do this
anymore I want to do something else with
my life
1995 is a big year where we ship product
conveniently called Windows 95 and our
software's doing well and we emerge we'd
always have the greatest depth of
engineering and we were slightly the
biggest but we really emerges the
successful company and and so I started
thinking about wow you know there's a
lot of value here at Microsoft what of
other philanthropists done historically
so during the 90s I'm thinking about
that my mom tragically passes away in
the same year as I get married 1994 my
dad is volunteering to help out think
about the philanthropy piece so it was
in the year 2000 that I put twenty
billion dollars into the foundation and
you know then it became the the biggest
foundation at that point you mentioned
you got married in 1994 you married a
Duke graduate how did you have time to
lose somebody when you're running your
company and how haven't much time to
that take well she was an employee of
Microsoft and we'd run into each other
actually New York City City we ended up
sitting together in a dinner and she's
an amazing person and you know kind of
caught me by surprise how much that
engaged my attention even versus all
this exciting Microsoft stuff I was
doing so we you know dated on and off
for about five years and then decided to
get married so you have decided that
your foundation would focus principally
but other things as well but principally
on health in Africa and K to 12
education United States is that right
yeah health of all the poorest but big
Africa's paradigm addict so how did you
come to those conclusions that those are
the two things you wanted to work on as
opposed to everything else we talked
about it a lot
so that's the decision that Melinda and
I made we wanted to take the greatest
injustice in the world something that we
could make a huge difference in and
that's health now we brought that a bit
by doing agriculture and sanitation's
and other things and then we wanted to
take a cause that would help the u.s. be
as strong as it could and in that case
trying to help improve educational
opportunity is our big thing you and
Melinda go into the field why do you
feel you need to go into the field in
Africa or Latin America any part of the
world where you're giving away money and
actually meet people that you're giving
money to and learn well I've chosen to
spend my time and Melinda spends her
time building the foundation is an
institution that really has an impact
and I get a lot of enjoyment this is you
know how I've taken everything I've
learned from Microsoft and the position
I'm in and helping to drive the strategy
and go out and see what's going on with
this work that's my full-time job and
it's a wonderful job your foundation has
a certain life it's not a perpetual
foundation is that I think it's a 20
years after either you or your wife the
last one to live dies that it would end
is that how it works that's right the
way that we're managing the institution
and keeping it excellent and designing
it to solve problems that can be totally
solved so we work on malaria this
foundation should be able to participate
in getting rid of that all these
infectious diseases that so
disproportionately hurt the poor and
really explain most the difference
between why a poor child has a 50 times
greater chance of dying than a child in
a wealthy country in 30 or 40 years
those problems should have been brought
to an end and whatever the new problems
philanthropy should go after the people
who are alive then and picking great
executives and building institutions and
go solve they'll do a much better job
and then we can just writing down a
little guidance so it is a limited-time
foundation it's okay he let there be a
dialog when your mother first said I'd
like you to come and have dinner with me
and Warren Buffett will be here you
should meet him you didn't seem that
interested why was that well Warren I
thought it was somebody who bought and
sold securities which is a very zero-sum
thing that's not curing disease or a
cool piece of software and the idea of
you know kind of looking at volume
curves and it doesn't invent anything
and so I thought my way of looking at
the world what I wanted to figure out do
and what he looked at that there
wouldn't be much intersection and that's
why it was so shocking when I met him he
was the first person to really ask me
about software and software pricing and
why wasn't IBM with all of their
strengths able to overwhelm Microsoft
and what what was going to happen in
terms of how software would change the
world and you know he let me ask him
about okay well why do you invest in
certain industries and why are some
banks more proper than others and he was
clearly a broad systems thinker and so
it started a conversation that has been
fun and enriching and you know an
incredible friendship that was
completely unexpected and he taught you
how to play bridge or did you already
know I know how to play bridge but I had
done it just our family had done it and
then because Warren it was a chance to
spend time with Lauren I renewed my
bridge skill at first very poorly but
both golf and bridge were things that we
did in our hour hours that we got to
goof off together you've given up on
golf well Warren gave up on golf a few
years ago and so my primary excuse to
play golf has gone away so I'm I'm
golfing not much now tennis is become my
my primary sport Warren Buffett called
you one day and said by the way I'm
going to give you most of my money were
you surprised when he said he wanted to
give you all this money from his wealth
to your foundation that was a a complete
surprise because
Warren is the best investor and he's
built this unbelievable company and he
was giving me advice about all the
things I was doing I was learning so
much from him but his wealth was devoted
to a foundation that his wife was in
charge of and so tragically she passed
away and so then he had to think that is
his initial plan wouldn't make sense and
and much to my surprise he decided that
a part of the wealth a little over 80%
of it would come to our foundation so it
was a huge honor a huge responsibility
you know an incredible thing because it
let us raise our level of ambition even
beyond what we would have done without
that that you know in my most
definitions the most generous gift of
all time and you started with Warren and
Melinda The Giving Pledge what is that
about and how is that work well Warren
was brainstorming with us about how did
philanthropists figure out what to do
and what how could they kind of help
share with each other without giving up
the diversity what they did and so he
got us to do some dinners with people
who are already doing amazing
philanthropy and talk about how they
built staff and picked causes and not
that they would give to the same things
but that they would the quality and even
the the how early people get engaged
would be enhanced by the people getting
together and making a public commitment
to give the majority of their wealth
away and so that's become the Giving
Pledge group you're the wealthiest man
in the world for 20 years or more how
does it affect your life daily people
come up to you all the time and ask for
money or they expect you to buy them
things we've gotten tired of it
you
[Music]
when you were doing Microsoft the
beginning you were doing the coding
yourself and you could presumably no
more than coding they just about anybody
but now if you have so many other
responsibilities when Microsoft develops
a new piece of software are you able to
really talk to the software engineers in
the same level that you could 20 years
ago well I'm certainly nowhere near as
hands-on as I was when I would either
write the code or look it over and hire
all the programmers and in my career
this evolution of being an individual
performer than a manager or manager
managers and then setting broad strategy
you have to get used to the fact you
don't have as much control but I try and
understand enough about software that
the trade-offs were making about what
feature should we put in what the basic
design should be I still enjoy those
discussions and even today over at
Microsoft we get to talk about ok what
should the next office do you know how
can Windows be better how's the user
interface going to change when we have
speech and handwriting and those things
so I'm able to participate but it is a
way more complex field and you know I
couldn't actually write all the code
myself anymore when somebody turns on
their computer today they have to have
three fingers usually and they put a
finger on ctrl alt and delete and it
seems a little awkward to do that why
did you do that and why do people have
to have that mechanism to turn on the
computer well fortunately most machines
nowadays have moved away from that but
the idea that we knew that there was
logic in the keyboard that could detect
a truly unique single signal that would
bypass the software that was running so
you could know it was really starting
over
clearly that ended up being an awkward
piece of user interface if we had to do
it over again we wouldn't do it it sort
of was in the chasm between Microsoft
and IBM then it ended up being that way
and you know it's kind of
the poster child of hate couldn't you
have made the stuff a little simpler
so you're the wealthiest man in the
world for 20 years or more how does it
affect your life daily people come up to
you all the time and asked for money or
they expect you to buy them things
fortunately people know that that wealth
is dedicated to the foundation and so
they have ideas that are in the
Foundation's area infectious disease
improving education then it's super
interesting to have them talk to hear or
talk to those people I have the the
benefit of being well-known so I can go
out meet interesting people and you know
share my views and get a lot of
attention
I'd say net that's a benefit when I'm
out with the kids then it can be you
know a tiny bit of a drawback that you
you may not get as much privacy as you'd
like but overall it you know I my
success has allowed me to you know get
more done build partnerships you know
meet great people how do you deal with
it when you want to go shopping or you
don't don't go to shop I go shop I go
out to the theater people don't come up
to unite hi for selfies or something
they can yeah but that's that's pretty
quick I and people are usually very nice
about it what about your children
everybody who's wealthy who has children
has to deal with how do you train your
children to live with the wealth how
much do you give them and how do you get
them involved in philanthropies well our
kids are young enough that the key focus
is helping them you know enjoy learning
get a great education all of them will
pick careers that aren't related to
software philanthropy they will strike
out in their own direction and be great
you know in their own way whatever it is
they picked to do so we've chosen that
they'll have enough wealth that they'll
never be poor anything but we're not
going to take billions of dollars and
have that defined their life the vast
majority of the wealth is dedicated to
the
the foundation and so far you know
they're they're great kids and you know
they they enjoy learning about what
we're doing in African you know that may
shape where where they go with their
lives but it'll be up to them when
people look back on what you've done 20
years from now or 30 years from now what
would you like to have people say Bill
Gates achieved I don't think it's
important for me to be remembered
specifically I do hope that infectious
disease is largely eliminated as a
problem so that nobody's having to talk
about it and people can focus on other
issues that would be a huge great thing
if our work has helped improve us
education that would be a huge great
thing you know most importantly are that
people who really know me my kids that
you know they feel I was a good father
gave them an opportunity to go create
their own own life